Now let’s consider the slightly more difficult
situation where we have two shark objects
within our image.
Now you and I looking at this image can clearly
see that there are two distinct regions; we’re
not confused at all.
But for the machine vision system that we’re
building, we need to develop an algorithm
that can determine that there are two distinct
regions here.
If we apply the technique of moments that
we just looked at and compute the moments
of this scene, what we will end up with is
the centroid of a region, which contains the
two sharks.
We see the centroid in between the two sharks.
It hasn’t been able to work out that they’re
separate, it’s just treated all the white
pixels in the same way, and we see also that
the bounding box is drawn around the extremities
of both sharks, rather than around the sharks
individually.
We need some way to distinguish between these
two objects.
Now the way that we do this is to transform
the image.
So here is our input image and were going
to perform a transformation; it’s a process
called connectivity analysis, and the output
image is shown on the right.
We refer to this as a label image, and what’s
interesting about the labelling image is that
all of the pixels that belong to the same
object are assigned the same label.
So we see that all of the pixels that belong
to the top shark have been labelled 1.
All of the pixels that correspond to the bottom
shark have been labelled 2, and all of the
pixels that belong to the background have
been labelled 3.
In this image the pixel values refer to the
label of the object if you like; to describe
which of the n objects in the scene those
pixels belong to.
This is a really powerful transformation.
The white objects in the input scene are called
blobs.
‘Blobs’ is actually a technical term—you’re
allowed to use it.
In this input scene there are three blobs,
shark 1, shark 2 and the background, and in
the output image the pixels have got values
1–3, indicating which blob they belong to.
So what is a blob?
It’s also known as a region, and sometimes
it’s called a connected component.
It’s a set of contiguous pixels of the same
colour that are next to each other; they touch
each other.
And when we talk about colour, before we’ve
just been looking at a binary image where
the pixels are either black or white.
Often times we’ll start with a real colour
image, and the first processing stage is to
convert that colour image into a boundary
image.
So in the top example here we have a scene
with four yellow objects in it.
And we perform some image processing operations
and we’ll talk about this in future lectures,
to convert the yellow pixels to being true—or
white—and all the other colour pixels to
being false—or black.
In the bottom example we’re trying to find
the tomatoes on the bush, and we’re going
to use image processing techniques that give
us a true result when the pixel is red and
a false result when it is not red.
So the first step is to take a real colour
image, convert it into a binary image where
the pixel values are either true or false,
and then we can apply our connectivity analysis
to that image.
The label that we assign to a pixel indicates
which set it belongs to.
Every pixel has the same label as its neighbour
to the north, south, east or west that has
the same colour.
This is a fundamental part of the connectivity
analysis algorithm.
Now this process of performing connectivity
analysis has many names.
Sometimes it’s called connected component
analysis; sometimes it’s called blob or
region or image labelling; sometimes it’s
called blob or region colouring.
Many names, the same algorithm.
Here is our original binary image with two
sharks in it, and now in the middle we have
the label image where the pixels have got
values of 1, 2 or 3 depending on whether pixels
belong to shark 1, shark 2 or the background.
Now I can apply a simple logical test to this
image, and I can say give me all of the pixels
that have got a label value of 1.
I end up with this binary image that contains
just one shark, the top shark.
And once I have this image I can apply the
techniques we used previously to find the
centroid and the bounding box of this particular
shark.
Now I can ask for a binary image, which contains
all of the pixels that are labelled 2, and
I have an image, a binary image which contains
just the bottom shark.
Once I have this shark in isolation I can
apply the earlier techniques and again find
its bounding box and its centroid.
Now the background is also a blob.
It’s all of the pixels that are labelled
3.
So we can say what is the image where all
of the pixels are equal to 3, and we see here
it is basically the background with shark
shaped holes in it.
It’s a blob as well; it’s a very large
blob.
It touches the edge of the image and it’s
got these two holes in it, which are the objects
in the foreground.
If we compute the moments of the background
below we find that it’s got a centroid which
is roughly in the middle and it’s got a
very large bounding box which goes around
the whole outside of the image.
Now we have a binary image, or logical image,
that contains two blobs.
So let’s compute the label image.
The function that we use has actually got
two output arguments.
The first output argument, L is the label
image itself, and the second output argument
is the number of blobs it finds within the
scene.
The function itself is called ilabel and we
parse in the binary image.
So it’s computed L, which is an image, and
the number of blobs, which has got a value
of 3, so it’s saying there, are 3 blobs
within this scene.
There are the two sharks, and the background
blob.
So let’s display the label image and investigate
that.
Start a new figure and display the label image.
Let’s have a look at some of the pixel values
within that.
So these pixels here, all the ones that I’m
clicking on, have got a value of 3.
That means these pixels belong to blob number
3, which is the background blob.
All of these pixels here in this shark are
all labelled 1; that is, they all belong to
blob number 1.
These pixels down here all have a value of
2, so these pixels all belong to blob number
2.
Now what we can do is use a logical operation,
a logical test on the labelling of each in
order to isolate the different blobs within
the image.
What I can do now is to display all the pixels
who have a label equal to 1, and what we see
now is that there is just a single shark in
this scene.
Let’s have a look at all the pixels that
have got a label equal to 2 and now we see
the second shark.
So now what we’ve got is a scene with a
single blob in it, and this is a problem we’ve
met before.
We know how to work out the bounding box of
a scene that contains a single blob; we know
how to compute the centroid, and the area
of a scene that contains just a single blob.
So by using this intermediate step of labelling
the image, we can turn our complex problem
with multiple regions into a problem that
we have seen before.
An extra level of sophistication that we can
go to is to use the function iblobs.
I parse in the image—that’s all I need
to do—and it’s returned a vector of blob
objects.
Technically, they are region feature objects.
And there’s one object for each region or
each blob in the scene.
So element number 1 is a blob with an area
of 7827.
We can see its centroid.
We can see is colour; that is, that it comprises
pixels with the value of 1.
We can see its label; it’s got a label value
of 1, and a couple of other parameters as
well which we will get to in due course.
Blob number 2 also has an area of 7827 It’s
another shark.
And blob number 3 has got a very large area;
and we can see its colour is equal to 0, so
that is the background blob.
Let’s show again the original image.
Here we go, here’s the scene with two sharks
in it.
For the first element in this vector of blobs,
that’s blob number 1, I can plot a bounding
box and I can do that in the colour green
… there we go.
For blob number 2, I can plot its bounding
box in green.
I can also plot the centroid of the object
and I will plot that in blue and I’ll draw
an asterisk there.
The blobs have also got a number of parameters
or attributes.
So, for instance, for blob number 1 I can
say what is its area.
We can look at the colour of that particular
blob; we use the class attribute, and see
that it is comprising pixels with a value
of 1.
We can look at the centroid using the p attribute
and we see a vector here, which contains the
u and v coordinates of its centroid.
We can get the individual elements, uc is
the u coordinate of the centroid.
We even find the moments have been stashed
away, so the 0,1 moment of that particular
blob has got this particular value.